Thanks so much for
giving us that extra insight into
how you use websites Victor.
>> Sure my pleasure.
>> If you could have our students take
away just two things from this lesson
what would they be?
>> First of all make sure to
use meaningful headings and
link text as well as good pay structure.
Secondly, as a general rule,
you shouldn't try to control
the experience a screen
reader user will have.
They will use the information
available to them
because the tool they're using to find
that information on the web page.
Things such as trying to control or fine
tune exactly what a screen reader says,
or make an elements focusable
which shouldn't be,
generally lead to more confusion and
worse experience for users.
>> That's really helpful
advice thank you.
Now and our next lesson, we're going to
take a look at what we can do if HTML
doesn't have the precise semantic we
need or if, for some reason or other,
the HTML element we'd usually use isn't
a good fit for some other reason.
[BLANK_AUDIO]